hello guys my name is Hoshino and
welcome to episode 125 of game
programming so last time we did a few
things with layers and whatnot and I
actually put up a video recently about
what is going on exactly with everything
and and this channel and whatnot and I
talked a little bit about game
programming not really but basically the
deal with game programming is that this
series has been going on for way too
long
and I really am eager to kind of close
it and package it away and write it off
as it complete a series so in order for
us to do that we have to finish it so MA
it's the best thing what I'm going to be
doing over the next few months is
finishing it off okay so I'm going to
add in pretty much every feature that
you guys want I'm not going to I'm not
going to keep adding content I'm going
to keep adding like framework features
essentially if that makes any sense so
what I mean by that is that I'm going to
kind of set up a skeleton for pretty
much everything and really the only
thing that this game is going to lack is
content okay it's still going to contain
enough content for you to play the game
and for you to see what it is but it's
not going to have as much content as say
again that I would typically release on
Steam or something right it's not going
to be up to that point is going to just
kind of have enough for you guys to
learn from and that is that is the
entire point of this series anyway so I
asked you guys on Twitter and I'm going
to actually keep doing this quite
regularly but I asked you guys on
Twitter what you actually wanted to see
and the results have been let me just
quickly log in and see a little also
because for some reason I logged out
alright so the results on Twitter I've
been I asked you guys if you want to see
the inventory or multiplayer and as you
can see it was actually kind of closed
56 votes here and most of the people
voted for multiplayer but it was kind of
closed it wasn't like I was actually
expecting it to be much further apart so
it was kind of close here and and
multiplayer as you can see won the race
so I'm going to keep doing polls like
these for help from you guys as to what
you want to see and whatnot I think it's
a really good idea so to take part of it
and it's really easy to bro you just
literally click the button
that's it so just follow me on Twitter
so the Cherno is my twitter name the
link will be in the description and I
will be doing a lot more of this and
you'll be able to stay up to date that
way but anyway the point is we are doing
multiplayer so that's pretty crazy
because I didn't really imagine doing
multiplayer so quickly but we will be
doing multiplayer so what I want to do
today is I just want to set up
multiplayer alright I don't want to
actually start getting into server code
and client code and all that stuff
because the biggest problem with
multiplayer is that most games just
simply are not set up to handle it
properly we're going to talk a bit about
how we're actually going to implement
multiplayer and what multiplayer even
means for this game but today we're just
going to take a look take a take a bit
of time to prepare this entire code base
and it'll actually probably take a bit
of time here
but we're going to prepare this entire
code base so that it is ready to
actually embrace multiplayer right
because we don't want to the current
state of it there are there are some
considerations as I've taken in this
code to basically not make it impossible
to learn to implement multiplayer so we
don't need to rewrite code but there are
a few things that we need to add and a
few things that we need to basically
inspect and that's what we're going to
do today and I'm also going to talk
about multiplayer and how that's going
to work so if we launch our game right
now let's talk about what multiplayer
will mean for this game so ideally what
will happen this is going to be a huge
project I imagine this will take several
months especially with the write that
I'm putting out videos and that
collision does not seem right anyway so
the idea with multiplayer in the way
that this is probably going to work and
if you guys have anything that you
disagree with or or you think that maybe
I'm kind of thinking of a bad way to do
things or you think that I should add
this functionality instead or you think
the game should behave good or you think
that the game should behave differently
anything like that just leave a comment
below and I will bring this up in the
next video don't you worry or maybe the
video after that but probably in the
next video I'm going to put up this
video wait a bit of weight like a few
days and then make another one so that
way I've taken all your feedback and one
on but um basically
the way this is probably going to work
right now and at least the way that I
imagine this is that when you launch
this it's going to ask you to log in
right and you're going to have to log in
in some way maybe if you've already
logged in before or just remembers the
fact that you are logged in and
automatically logs you in or something
like that but the idea is everyone has a
username and a password
you log in and then it takes you into a
lobby with a lot of people okay so for
example it just joins you right into the
game and then like for now we will
support like one instance of the game
per server okay so if you want another
instance you just run another server on
a different port or something but the
idea right now is that you will get put
into this map with other players okay
and there will probably be no limit to
the amount of players obviously that's
obviously the more players that you
actually add the slower it's going to be
especially for the server and if the
server isn't very good
but I'm not going to be like okay twenty
players that's it
I think this should be able to handle
about 100 I wouldn't I would be quite
surprised if it can't handle a hundred
it should be able to handle like
thousands like theoretically but because
we won't be sending much done at all or
doing really any validation to begin
with at least so this should be this
should be a walk in the park for a
competent server here but um essentially
what we'll be doing for now is yeah
making it so the client opens up and you
can join you'll be automatically put
into a server I can only be one server
for now maybe we'll integrate some kind
of server browser in the future if the
need for that arises and if you guys
want I guess but for now that's that's
what's gonna happen at it and you'll be
able to walk around and see each other
and that's it so that's what we're going
for bare minimums here right we're going
for an environment that you can log into
and you'll be taken into a world where
there are many other players and you'll
be able to see them walk around and
that's it
interaction and chat for example that
stuff will probably come later if it is
requested but for now that's all I going
to do okay cool so that being said let's
kind of begin so the biggest thing in
this code base that probably needs to be
handled is support for basically having
more than one player because I I'm
pretty sure that I did remove a
so stuff like this right we have the
player who is the client player what's
very importance that there needs to be a
distinction between a client player and
an actual networked player okay so the
this player of which there is only one
of is the actual client player so that's
you that's when you actually join a
server it's actually you so this player
is the correct play this player is the
one that actually takes in user input
and then acts in a certain way okay
that's just how it works you can see the
key listener is essentially part of the
player and whatnot and this player is
the local player okay so very important
that you don't mess that up and it's
very important that you don't forget
about that distinction
we're probably also going to make a
player that is going to be a networked
player so that we don't really confuse
ourselves too much I'm actually going to
make a folder called net okay and
there's all of our net code is going to
go into into this folder alright this is
just kind of preparation and making sure
that we don't forget about any of that
now we're probably since we do have this
event system we're probably also going
to create events such as player
connecting play disconnecting and all
that stuff in the future but we're not
going to bother too much about that
right now so yes so very important that
we have a player that actually is
essentially a a mob that isn't this
player because you can see this player
actually has a lot of code and most of
it has to do with stuff like if input
dot down then move a certain way and
obviously this isn't something that we
want for a networked player okay so
that's the player stuff we did have a
lot of things in level which I actually
put in for example we had on a rate list
of players right now there were just a
bunch of player objects we might
externally send these to be just mobs or
something like that I'll see if I can
actually make kind of the multi player
player or the networked player actually
extend player I think that should be
possible probably not though it's
probably not a good idea to do that just
because we've got all the all these
things like UI stuff which we
might not want to have and player
anymore but nothing might be easier
easier to make a completely different
player or even make the local player
extent the network's player or some like
that so we have this ArrayList here
which you can see we have things like
get client player and get player apps
and in in the US and indices and we just
have this thing that should be called
get players really okay so we've got a
pretty good API built up here and we can
certainly add players and whatnot pretty
easily as well by just adding him into
this list and the cool thing is they'll
be rendered pretty well like the eyes
and they'll be handled pretty well and
they'll be rendered and updated and
everything like that automatically which
is quite great so for example if I was
to want to see where we add this current
stuff let me just test me out real quick
we add this new player at player as an
players for X&Y I don't know why this
class exists but whatever so 19 and 42
why does is alright because it yeah all
right fair enough
so 1942 let me just quickly take this
and pop it into level where do we have
US foreign level I might just do
something like add new player will put
null
yeah okay listener which might result in
problems
we'll put cheddar - and then will maybe
make it a little bit offset here so
let's see what this does
okay so before it crashed because of the
nullpointerexception from the input you
can see that we actually do have to play
isn't they're both being rendered and
the UI is all not very cool because
that's the second players UI anyway
we've got a few problems with the UI of
course but you consider that we now have
two players okay so the game supports
two players one I'm kind of kind of kind
of trying to get out and we don't need
to do too much about that but we do need
to bring in the whole concept of a
player that is not a local so in that
I'm going to make a folder called player
and in there I'm actually going to make
something I'll just call it the net
player all right okay so this net player
is going to extend mob just like the
other player did okay we're going to
have an update and we're gonna have a
render and then what update and then
what update and render will do render
will be very similar to player's render
our two players thing I imagine we're
also going to have to make some kind of
asset pipeline as well which retrieves
potential sprites because we might not
all want to have the same sprite I think
I think a worthwhile a worthwhile thing
to add to this game as well in terms of
the multiplayer aspect is for you to be
able to basically customize your
character and for other players to see
those customizations that you have so
we're going to have to design a whole
system for that as well but that's why
this player is going to be a bit
different as well because it's going to
use different sprites potentially let's
see what we can do right now though we
can probably do something like I've been
a lot of methods yeah right a tax
character and mob okay so it looks like
we've got draw rect and that's it as far
as do we not have a way to fill a
rectangle really
well what about too
okay let's just do that now then so
public void feel feel wrecked I guess
we'll do the whole fixed thing as well
so we have this here all right
so we'll just have two for loops that do
all this stuff for us
I'll fill every pixel of the rectangle
I'm really surprised that we don't have
this surely we've had a need to draw a
rectangle before bit weird but okay all
right and then we'll just say that if XP
sorry this should be honest fine what is
making offset so XR is going to be x
offset which is going to be XP plus X
and if X R is less than 0 or X R is
greater equal to this start with then
we'll continue we'll do the same thing
for y up here excuse me if I'm just
rushing through this by the way I just
really want to this is not the focus of
this episode so really this should have
been already in the game pixels XR + yr
times it's still we're equals color okay
so we now got a filled rectangle method
which pretty follows so fill rectangle
let's see so we'll have x + y in here
with and hi it will just set to like I
think thirty twos I'm no idea but I
think 32 is maybe 16 that's probably 16
yeah maybe no it's not a 32 that was
half a thing color we'll just do
something like a nice blue maybe and
then fixed will be
Kru fix is fixed what I think it is yes
so the fix will be true and we now
should have this player situation so
what we'll do here is there's a few ways
that we could imply that everything has
to be a net player we could definitely
say that player it's dense net player we
wouldn't get many problems with
functionality if I don't imagine we'll
do just for now we might actually do
that but it might be wiser to actually
make it like an interface or something
like that because I don't imagine this
would be that useful but for now we're
going to just take the easy route and
say that they're going to be entities
possibly mobs actually because they are
both bombs
all right so there we go everyone plot
that and we'll go down here we'll just
need to quickly change this stuff so see
unfortunately stuff like this for me to
this is also important as well because
it might not be we I think we should
make some kind of intermediate player
class but right now I'm not really going
to bother with that client player will
definitely be cast to just normal player
though all right cool so and then this
will just be yeah okay so this isn't
okay
we've even got to get players which
returns everything so that's kind of
nice so we have nobody we right now we
have no way of knowing if it's going to
be a net player or not so we'll have to
actually go back and call these just
mobs where is where was that method at
why main here all right
there we go but there we go so a few
things that we've changed here so this
isn't chase that move so it okay so this
gets all players again we don't actually
have to have this be a play you can see
this will still work with it just being
a mob okay cool so there we go we've got
a few things going on here everything
you can still work as it did before
which is good and then finally we'll
actually add some kind of net player and
we'll figure out a way to do that so we
need some kind of system which will
essentially listen for certain states
and act upon them so we need some kind
of like client-side server if that makes
any sense probably doesn't but what I
mean is we need to have some kind of
system in the network which want our
client actually that receives commands
from the server so not sure how we'll do
that exactly there are many ways to
implement something like that we'll
probably just have that as part of the
netcode over here so it needs access to
most of the game and it needs to be able
to change the game based on information
that it gets from the server okay so
we'll be implementing that next time but
for now that in game I'm just going to
do something like we'll make something
in level let's see I'm just on the add
so again we've got this instance of
player situation that I don't want to
deal with right now but we'll have a
public void add player mop mop mop
player players dot add player and
players or player dot init to this okay
there we go so now this is also adding
that is game now so if we were to do
something like level dot player which
you could do here as well by the way new
net player
then I um where is that being rendered
at X&Y
so probably just make a public nest
player x equals like 22 i think so x 16
and y equals like 42 laying yeah that's
tribute that should be in out pigeon
yeah so here is our net player okay cool
so there we go there's our rectangle and
that's pretty much how that cookie
crumbles so next time we're going to
actually do some that stuff I'm going to
get into that this episode I just wanted
to explain what was going on really and
show you guys some basics as to how
we're going to do this and what we're
going to do just so you guys can get all
excited and and I can get excited and we
can get this done but next time we're
going to probably start off with a
server and client type of deal so we'll
be making a new project over here which
is essentially going to be the rain
server my call is like rain cloud or
something that's actually a nice name I
like that rain cloud because it's like a
cloud computing type server deal and
that's nice I like that name anyway
we'll make like a rain cloud or a storm
cloud or something that maybe rain cloud
I like rain cloud anyway we'll be making
rain cloud next time now I'm excited and
and we're going to just set up a basic
client server type deal
okay so just with sending like text to
and from first and then we'll start
sending more useful data and we will
maintain connections and whatnot and
we'll have a lot of fun because this
stuff can be fun this stuff can be
terrible if you don't know how to do it
but luckily we know how to do it so
we'll be fine anyway I'll see you guys
next time thanks for watching a few
things I wanted to mention just before I
go I actually made a slap channel so
slack if you guys haven't heard of it
slack is essentially a I wanted to have
like an IRC chat system back in the day
but it just it wasn't very good it
wasn't a really good idea because well
really the child channel chat situation
was that it was on IRC it was very hard
to maintain it's very old-school what
you wanted said if you want to have
something called slack so slack is like
I'll kind of show you guys what slack
looks like I'm the only one currently in
here but basically slack is like you can
you can go to it from a web browser
there's a Windows like desktop
application for it there's a mobile
application for it so you guys can
always stay up to date it's really meant
for teams of people working together but
you can use it just for communities as
well it's very popular to use for that
as well such as our community you can
see that there's a few different I've
made a few different channels general
and random of like the default channels
and you can see that random just about
talking about whatever general is like
just really anything that isn't
applicable to the other channels but is
kind of you know I guess relevant to to
me to the channel and all the content
that I put out and all the community
stuff game programming is about this
series so if you want to talk about game
programming if you've got some problems
or whatever this is like a real-time
chat system so if I say something like
this you know it's like it's an instant
messenger type deal and you can even
post pictures here and all that stuff so
it's really cool and then Sparky of
course will be about Sparky and I've
even had an integration to like github
so they'll build out there's actually a
bot here that whenever someone opens
opens a new issue or I commit something
to Sparky it'll actually just post here
so it's a really good thing to just have
kind of in your background and you'll
get notifications and one on all right
you won't even have it on your phone and
then every time something happens for
example or someone's talking to you or
there's something you know there's
something that's being talked about
he'll get a notification so it's very
very cool I really I really want I
really wanted to for a while get on to
like a kind of broaden this community
and have it be a bit more close together
and I think that something like slack is
a very good tool for that so if you want
to join this it's very very simple you
have to have it you just have to head
over to slacked off the channel comm so
this was the channel slack comm that's
where you go when you've actually
already been added to this it's very
easy to register for this as well you
just go to slack daughter channel comm
link will be in the description enter
your email address hit join you'll get
an email with an invitation and then
you'll be able to log into this and and
chat away so anyway I think it's a very
good idea we'll see how it goes but I
will try
this this will this app is on my phone
okay so if you at any point want to say
something to me you can even direct
message me I'm gonna go ahead and say
don't do that too often because I don't
want to get bombarded with messages but
if you just generally have questions the
one off I'll be chilling in here pretty
much 24/7 because it'll be on my phone
so um mmm it's definitely the best way
to get in touch and hopefully meet new
people and maybe even work on projects
if you guys have suggestions for more
for more channels as well I will
definitely be creating some new ones and
in fact I'm pretty sure you can even
create your own channels so I might have
to moderate that a little bit a little
bit but hopefully not hopefully it'll be
very smooth okay the other thing I
mentioned was of course I am on patreon
if you support me on patreon by giving
at least $5 per month then you will get
access to the entire source code
repository of off game programming okay
so simple as that you want this code
commit by commit as well I like after
this episode I'm just about a commit
with all my changes and whatnot then
just join up there and you will get
access to that on github which is pretty
pretty cool so anyway thanks for
watching guys I hope you enjoyed this
episode if you did please hit the like
button and I'll see you guys next time
with some more exciting multiplayer
stuff good bye
you